what kind of superhero would i want to
play maybe
maybe spiderman in like 10 years time
maybe
fans we are here with tom holland who
plays peter parker this is one of the
biggest spider-man films ever made i
honestly cannot even begin to explain to
you how happy i am and how excited i am
if you had told me 10 years ago that
you'll be playing spider-man in a movie
like this i would have been like you're
a liar
i've been a huge fan of these movies
since i was a kid i remember seeing
toby's movies i remember seeing andrew's
movies
i love performing like i think being on
stage is really like where i belong i
think that's my calling in life is being
on stage i love myself you know in a
good way you know not in a way like oh
i'm so [ __ ] handsome
i just really enjoy my life i'm just so
happy in my own skin and and i think i'm
very lucky to be that way you know i
think for me instagram is the most
important thing to like keep control
over because it's quite easy for
instagram to be a very fake version of
your life
i'd like to try and keep my instagram
lively and let people know that i'm a
bit of an idiot and a goofball and stuff
just because i don't want to have an
instagram that's just like oh look at me
right i think that is a testament to my
parents and how they brought me up you
know like i meet a lot of kids now who
are obviously very shy and i get that
you know because they're meaning like
meeting spider-man but when i was a kid
my parents would force me to speak to
adults like i hated it i absolutely
hated it but they were like come and
have a conversation look them in the eye
shake their hand like it was all about
trying to connect with people and i
think i've always been very good at that
and tried i try and stay away from my
phone even though it's impossible to do
that sure but i think my parents did a
great job with helping me connect with
people especially older people because
i've spent my whole career working with
adults right so from a very young age
when i finished billy elliot
all of my friends were like 30 years old
and i was like 12.
do you want to go for a pint i'm like
i'm six years too young bro
my big thing about actors is you can't
take yourself seriously if i pretended
to be serious that would be so stupid
like i dress up in red and blue tights
every day and pretend to be a superhero
like that's the most stupid thing i've
ever heard so if i took myself seriously
you just kind of lose perspective of
what it is that you're doing and stuff
and and it's my that's my pe hate about
acting is how people can take it and
we're so revered and so talented like i
just i think there isn't enough credit
that goes to people like surgeons and
engineers and architects and people who
have like a real skill right and can do
amazing things he's just so sweet and
humble
and he's kind of remained that way i
mean he's
he's a man now but he's just also just a
really decent human being
yeah
let's talk about spider-man so were you
a fan growing up huge fan a huge huge
fan yeah and how did you find out you
got this role that's a huge thing to get
this role i basically had been
auditioning for about five months
and
after my final audition they said you'll
find out tomorrow
fast forward six weeks i was still
waiting still waiting and one day marvel
just posted on their instagram
go to our website to find out who the
new spider-man is and that's it i just
found out online it did they didn't call
me up or anything so i ran downstairs i
was going ballistic my poor dog tessa
was terrified um and my brother harry
who's pretty savvy with technology and
stuff was like dude they've probably
been hacked bro like
they would call you right they would let
you know and um so i called my agents
they were like oh this is amazing and
then kevin feige finally ran me and said
i've got some great news you're gonna be
spider-man i was like i know kevin you
put it on